you're on my list of like the five
people that like I want to do it and I
want to be there so I'm like so that's
why I was like God can I just be
rescheduling on like Trevor Wallace
right now like I'd rather someone when
someone reschedules two things happen
number one I go I'm feel like we're
closer than I thought we were because
they know they can reschedule on me like
I want to be the person that no one has
to go like she's gonna be back low-key
same she's gonna talk shit whatever I
get that I get that because I I try to
give that energy because like life is
life in certain people obviously the
type A of it all but you and I are
similar I know that you don't schedule
planning on rescheduling like shit
happens and shit comes up it's it really
is right now with life with tour trying
to put tour with all my shit I literally
I was gonna ask you on the podcast like
how the fuck do you Whitney I'm gonna
get into it but also we have to when
someone reschedules I say this with love
in my heart knowing I'll see you yeah
you're just giving me two hours that I
didn't think I was gonna have I love you
so much you were just like me fucking
for real that's what we are someone
bails on us and we're like yes you
totally you're just like I thank you so
much
oh smoke a little weed and watch
Labyrinth okay it'll change your life
okay am I allowed to be I mean you could
do whatever you want and I anything I
want to get the baby blow it I don't
want the baby just to be too big when it
comes out
please are you are you gonna C-section
are you gonna just fucking
just like queef that shit yeah
absolutely pull up my knee I at first
was like I should do C-section so I
don't ruin my vagina right yeah and then
I talked to a bunch of men I stopped
asking women love women want to talk to
me about childbirth I want to get like
give me all the whatever cheat codes but
I went to like guys now is it making
pussy bigger like is it change is it not
as small and like I noticed no
difference like I stopped asking women
and I started asking men and then I
started watching videos of childbirth my
algorithm is a mess and uh and it's not
that your vagina gets so big the baby's
head gets smaller and
no keep going
I love it look after your trip to Paris
I feel like I feel like you've given
birth in a lot of ways that was the only
time in my life where I was taking a
dick and in that moment I thought maybe
I can give birth
okay which is a horrible clip for
whoever's I did listen to the last
episode of your podcast and I am I feel
so much better about having a child than
whatever happened to you in that Paris
hotel room well you just yeah you just
hope she does the kid doesn't turn out
like me for real that's all no I do yeah
I think you're the best we're not doing
this we're not you can do the
self-deprecating thing like it's fine I
like it so nice to me I was like I don't
talk about my friend like that you know
and also by the way you can like release
the late Jame like you can you know it's
I just have to say something like
there's something kind of freeing about
when
like you're the reschedule bitch and
it's okay it's a the ship sailed I know
it's like I really am chasing I'm just
gonna lean into it just be like I'm I'm
probably gonna have to reschedule it's
called self-care
you know what Whitney I'm clipping this
and I'm gonna get one of those digital
video frames that just replays and I'm
gonna put on my goddamn nightstand if
someone gives a shit that you reschedule
like that's their thing podcasting
you're showing up for free you're
showing it for free I'm not paying this
bitch
this is paying me in all the drink
company she has equity and not this one
it's liquid death I know why don't stop
drinking that on camera at least if
you're gonna be two hours late bitch
at least hold on that the fuck is this
no that's flavor that's a liquid death
flavored one promo code winning and so
and so podcasting when anyone shows up
I'm stunned for anybody
um when anyone shows up it's like we're
all doing each other favors we're all
doing this for free we're all doing this
for fans so when people show up it's
like an added bonus you you and I think
very similarly like shit because that's
how I feel like you were just like I
love when someone bails on me because I
have a free two hours and I was like I
say that all the time like when someone
bails Paige and I were like okay what
chain restaurants day are we about to
ruin you know like it's exciting as fuck
some exes let's go we just freed up my
afternoon Olive Garden am I gonna cost
someone out in right now like I'm stoked
but no one else really thinks about
mindset so I appreciate it and also when
someone cancels two or three times they
have to do it for sure now for sure four
fucking insurance
I wish it was like stiff socks podcast
you know like Whitney Cummings is an
idol of mine and there's no one you know
the fact that you even consider me a
friend means the world to me I'm so mean
to you I feel like instantly when I met
you I liked you
um and I just like vibrated on your
frequency I love my fucking heart I just
do I really like Brooke I really like I
love her like I love you guys brain and
then after I did your podcast we're
gonna get back to the double dildo thing
don't think you're out of that
tell me one wild sex story in exchange
oh no because French guys are wild I've
dated a couple french guys and um so I
love both of you together but ever since
I did your podcast I'll like when I go
out and about like every like 10th or so
person will be like how's Tana
and it's it's not like how's Hannah it's
like how is she people are people really
think I'm gonna die yeah and you know
what people are so goddamn concerned
about me I I go through that too I had
blue hair during the pandemic and it was
micro dosing oxytocin ketamine
okay I went through that too people were
like drafting obituaries yeah so I've
been been there too yeah had a little
bit of a weed problem uh in January
people were worried but it's not even
that it's not like is she gonna die it's
like people care like whatever you're
doing like you open up so much of
yourself and You're vulnerable and you
show yourself and you you know succeed
in public and you make mistakes in
public and you own it and people care
about you that's really fucking nice and
it means a lot to me I spent a lot of my
life being like why and I finally feel
like I'm at the place where I'm just
really grateful for it you know it's
still blows my mind when people like you
fucking care people that I really look
up to and like you know want to emulate
and just love so it's it's great you
know what I mean but I also I think that
is it is like even you like we share so
much that people are like how is she
like they're a little scared but it's
like everyone's doing the shit that
we're saying we just don't keep secrets
yeah you know we're just like brave
enough to like make the mistakes in
public and what you do and I hope I do
it too but I know that you do it is that
you show people an example of like
resilience you know what I mean like I
can recover from this it's fine and as
long as I like own it and admit it like
you can't get God if I've already got
myself 100 and I like love that about
you I was just talking about that I was
like I can be in a worldwide Scandal and
like not even know for five days because
like and then when I find out I'm like
ah and they're like I'm probably in some
Scandal and they're like actually you
are yeah that tracks yeah that
Bible happened two days ago but you're
on NBC I was like oh
sounds about right um you know okay so
you were in Paris and you hooked up with
a random stranger
just because they're French doesn't mean
they're less random and weird I don't
like why in my brain like that like I
would never do that in America same
thing with but only France two French
guys that I I met within four hours I
was in their home hotel room yeah I was
like why do I think you're safer just
because you're French because you guys
didn't do anything in World War II yeah
like I just I don't I don't know what it
is I don't know what it is like dude
French guys are gnarly dude they D they
eat snails yeah like as a snack what do
you think they're like in the bedroom
fucking lutely it is
it's I will like I really will be like
50 smoking a cigarette being like that
one time in Paris you know I don't have
no voice by then like I'm gonna be
talking out of one of those tubes
actually you're colonoscopy where you
needed no anesthesia
dead it changed my life you're really
dead after that yeah what it really is
but let me ask you are you kind of in a
place where you're like let me just go
with it because you're famous and like
you you do not think about stuff like
that like you don't worry this guy knows
who I am he's gonna be filming me he's I
do I I don't really I really don't hook
up with strangers I mean Define stranger
but like usually
all right so I don't know if you guys
are watching this or listening to it uh
but I'm gonna just do something real
quick which is I'm gonna bring a bowl
of beef off the floor that I've been
eating this is a factor meal I've been
eating Factor meals non-stop since I
have been pregnant because I am hungry
I'm hungry I'm low blood sugar my baby's
kicking I'm pissed I don't have time to
run to the grocery store and fight with
seven homeless people on roller skates
just to get a cart
okay I don't have that kind of time okay
factor is powering this baby's life okay
you get it you're too busy running
around during the day to think about
lunch okay keep your energy up with
lunch to go effortless wholesome meals
like grain bowls and salad Toppers that
are ready to eat when you're on the go
no microwave required isn't that genius
round out your meal and replenish your
snack Supply with an assortment of 45
plus add-ons including breakfast items
like our delicious apple cinnamon
pancakes check this this these are my
new favorite ones I am in my second
trimester of pregnancy and I just want
meat
meat meat that's all I want okay these
are my two favorites I brought them up
this one is the ground beef and cabbage
and it has some cheese in it this is the
spicy beef bowl that I've been eating
this entire time I'm not gonna eat it
now because you guys got mad at me
because you have missed the phonia and
you don't like it when people eat when
they do podcasts and then the cheesy
bacon ranch shredded chicken this is my
other Obsession I got some uh what are
the things
that hold tacos
taco shells yeah but the soft ones
tortillas I got some tortillas throw
them in the tortilla
deep throat that thing
tantrum averted
head to factormeals.com whitney50 use
code whitney50 to get 50 off that's wild
code whitney50 at factormeals.com
whitney50 to get 50 off stop being a
feminist and making food in a kitchen
just get this already in L.A really if
I'm hooking up with someone I you I know
them I know them through my friends
they're usually in my industry I've only
ever had one this wasn't even a
one-night stand with french guy because
we kept fucking but like I'm saying like
where I met someone and fucked them that
night this is I've only done that twice
in my entire life and let me ask you how
do you have a couple drinks like yeah
okay yeah but it's hard to do sober but
I did end up no I don't know if I fucked
him sober me looking to someone else
like it's your pussy to your pussy why
don't you know
um yeah I mean I was definitely loose
and whatever but I would do it sober I
love him I might fly him out and give
them like a weird random odd job in my
house and put them on salary just so he
can fuck me all the time let me ask you
okay so do you
sorry that's the sound of your asshole
he fucked you with a dildo so let me but
do you worry you're gonna get attached
emotionally are you like this is just
transactional
can you do that I ca I can't do that I
guess I'm weird I play Everything by ear
like each case is a new case yeah and I
feel like I'm the type of person that's
like so what if I get attached
emotionally it's a learning lesson it's
a chapter of my life not all people
and they're like yeah it will be chapter
15. friends being convenient it's like
just you're always like I'll get a joke
out of it if nothing else I I'm not
gonna lie really that's like how I feel
like if it's for the bit and it's for
the plot okay if I fall in love and I
marry this person okay like at the end
of the day you can't plan that out
anyways I'm gonna catch feelings for
this person I'm not for this person you
know yeah fuck it so let me okay so you
meet this guy you go back to his hotel
room see I I get a little bit delusional
when I when I hook up with someone I at
least want the delusion that you're not
with anyone else oh I play house or have
my husband with anyone else completely
no we're married and we're planning our
future and I get into it too I'll be
thinking like what if like whenever they
got married like I fully I'm playing
house every time I'm fucking someone I
really don't like it it's the only way
to get men to choke you these days
absolutely I couldn't agree more you
have to make crazy why Whitney I know
they pretend now they do like this
little fake joke where like no I have to
lean into your hand oh my God it's so
real have you ever and then you have to
like act you have to like uh yeah I'm
breathing yeah like I I want to see some
Stars pop a blood vessel in my eye and
that's where I'll catch a feeling come
on I want you to bring me to the brink
of death and back absolutely that's the
only way I'm gonna feel anything you
know what I mean I like a sweet I love
you sex like it is sweet it's good but
like if that can't be all it is I might
go back I like a little bit of
everything and you never know when
absolutely you I was thinking about you
the other day because you were talking
about when you sucked your baby daddy
stick for the first time you were
telling me this that like you were like
really hitting the GLOCK GLOCK 9000 you
know shout out call her daddy I do just
tears and then he was like Joker face
and then he just looked you and he was
like you don't have to hurt yourself or
something I don't maybe have a sucking
dick when I was thinking about this I
don't know it was too different this is
actually an ad that's two different
stories in one this has happened to me
twice actually one guy hi
um he was he did do theater so I
probably should have known
um and I yeah I went down on him and
just did like the very like like this
you know whatever yeah you got to get
the goods just the quick like yeah yeah
and there's that Penthouse spit and then
he went oh oh no no no no no no uh I
actually am not into when women hurt
themselves
what did you do did you just kiss it
like I just was like you're staring at
the dick you're like carrying the four
dividing my children I'm not into
hooking up with gay dudes yeah so how
about that okay that's that's so fast
and then yeah new dude I did he didn't
even let me go any further like he was
sitting on the edge of the bed and I
kind of just like went down and he he
went down with me and like met me now
he's like oh no no you don't have to do
that I love it you're also calling them
like the father of this child new dude
[Laughter]
I lost the baby
oh God it's like something feels caught
God I'm crying if you have a miscarriage
before my eyes right now will I tell the
story for the rest of my life yes will I
be concerned yes oh God she's probably
got like an ICU up in this fucking
conglomerate Mansion it just hung itself
on the umbilical cord hearing the story
of how little its mom respects itself
herself I don't I don't see gender
um and so so you walk in and he's a
french guy dude and he opens up like a
Pandora's box of sex toys that's the
thing I can't get past I know I it's
like the French Carrot Top no you like I
think so and why would I still fuck
Carrot Top to say have you fought Carrot
Top I haven't I really thought it was
gonna be I have but I wrote a lot of
really brutal jokes about him for the
Flavor Flav roast he was on one of the
Realms it was pretty bad I love your
life I love your life I'm into Carrot
Top I fuck with that child but so do you
does that make you feel like less
special well he told me and this could
be alive but here's the thing okay he's
nerdy like his look is nerdy like he
looked like Timothy chalamet was on like
Best Buy's Geek Squad so you're a
pedophile
I don't get the Timothy chalamet thing
like oh my God that's fair I could break
him in half I don't know same age same
age but
um
skinny always have big dicks always like
a horse every time and it's it's just
guaranteed almost you know with everyone
else your plan well not everyone else
but a lot of other archetypes of men
you're playing a guessing game yeah but
if they're tall and skinny you know well
because you're like they have nothing to
prove they're not like in ketosis 24 7
doing burpees like what are you making
up for yeah it's it's beautiful
um he told me he's only ever fucked like
six girls and I I don't sorry these all
for it could be a blame my I don't care
he fuck me so good he can fucking tell
me anything and I would just be like
okay slay I mean girlfriend guys tend to
be better at sex in general I do agree
with that yeah he gave
it's so weird to say that somebody who
put a double-ended dildo in my ass and
his ass gave innocent full Requiem for a
Dream pass
but he gave innocence still in like a
weird way you know what I mean but I
don't know she doesn't know what I mean
I might be like but if he's putting
okay so you brought up bubblogs I'm
still kind of confused what they do is
the idea of a butt plug that it makes
your vagina smaller from the inside do
you know like when people have like
those little charms on their phone and
they do nothing but they're cute
like they have no they have no sole
purpose in my Foundation friends yeah
correct like that's what I feel like a
butt plug is it's just like a fun
accessory like they're just like it's
hot like they're just looking at it you
know you won't fart well that's also
very fair and I kind of I'm down for
like a thumb in the ass like I think
it's fun and like a little butt plug
gives the same like it's nice it's nice
and I thought the idea is that you put
it up at an angle so that when he's
having sex with you I'm trying not to
curse because YouTube demonetizes
fucking everything now and I'm just like
so when you're winning
the idea is that it goes up and then his
penis hits it I didn't know that but
that sounds so right do you think it's
just like you're just unplugs you just
think it's like garnish for the asshole
like in my head it's giving like corsage
on a prom on a prom suit like it really
like the Apple in the pig's mouth when
they cook it like it doesn't really
enjoy like like rhinestones above the
eyebrows for no reason I've always just
thought a butt plug was like serious
asshole Decor how big are they I feel
like God
I think they vary in sizes yeah they do
definitely but I think that this I mean
also it
did
I really do have that smoke or wheeze
dude she's just Clowning me for my
absolutely they pull up and I like go to
open the door and I just hear
[Laughter]
fucking Licious if I show up next time
with a ventilator I think it's five
hours this is the Rodney Dangerfield
showing up for the box like I'm so why
oh my I mean it's sexy it's good you're
gonna die soon
someone's like how is Santa she took her
last breath on my podcast I mean there
was an article saying kids were just
dying from Vapes in high school right
and you were just like nah fake news no
I read it with the Vape in hand bro I
was like damn fuck for them I need to
stop but no you don't you don't need to
do anything do it whatever you want to
do yeah I don't think you know I don't
think people normally stop stuff when
they're like I need to stop you'll stop
when you're like ready to stop yeah or
just death bed you know yeah I don't
usually stop things so it's like too bad
yeah but let me ask you okay so he pulls
it I guess to me butt to butt there's so
many things you need to quit before
vaping there's like one it's like 99
problems in The Vaping one right that's
so fast on the list of things being like
what are we talking about right now and
I really debated telling the story
because I knew it would just supersede
me like it'd be six months from now and
it'd be like so tell me about the French
guy but I had to well okay so I can tell
you my weird French stories but I guess
to me I never I like putting up
something in a man's butt I think that
would be where I
and oh I've pegged I've done it uh-huh
it just went I just disassociated I'm
really sorry that you I know you just
saw God in the Hat Man and everyone
behind me like what how did I get here I
guess I need such a like animal like I
don't know it's a little bit no no
here's the thing I have to know they
also have that dog in them before I get
there
like you can't be a bitch and want it
like you've got to be like you gotta
dominate you gotta show me first that
like me pegging you so nothing in
comparison
doesn't mean you have to put on the
costume but you don't have to put on
like a strap-on right like Bluetooth
ones now
giving you cancer
the last time I picked someone it wasn't
fuck Whitney I just wanted to talk about
stand up let's talk about that no no no
it's okay the last time if you stand up
after you escapades maybe we wouldn't be
in this Jam this one like was like okay
so it's like fuck you're not getting
monetized on this one seriously have
someone else
it's just going on yeah there's so it's
like the strap-on and then like a little
like hook them a thing a hook yeah that
just goes like around to your butt yeah
it stays on so it wasn't like the whole
stick okay I would do the whole stick
though it's kind of funny okay and
that's the thing as well the first time
I ever picked someone it was like I just
want to see if I can give this
motherfucker to do it sure sure you know
before I break up with his ass yeah I'm
in a weird place where to me the
kinkiest shit is just like straight
missionary well you're pregnant yeah
that's true
like I hope you've gotten the majority
of things out of your system yeah uh
yeah it's weird things evolve and change
like things change like what you're into
like I don't know like I I'm no I'm in
I'm jealous like I'm into when I was
like in my 20s I was just like what do
you want me to do I was just like a I
didn't know I was like so insecure about
my body and so just like I didn't know I
mean I yeah I get what you're saying I
feel like in my I'm trying to get things
out of my system yeah I'm like done
though at this point that really was
kind of an anomaly I'm try I've been
really wholesome sexually not really
awesome that was I just lied to you but
like the shit that I'm into isn't it
weird where if someone lies and said I
just lied you'd like them more than if
they hadn't lied at all yeah I fully
fully agree it's a little grit and it's
also it's like a little like trick you
can do to make people think you never
lie yeah I lie so now
but now if you lie in the future and
don't say I just lied I'm like she's so
honest whoa she's so honest she like
tells me when she lies that's why
honestly I never thought about like that
so true Brooke does that she's so much
smarter than me she taught me that it's
really smart she taught me I just lied
yeah it's really I'm the kind of person
that does that will then lie and not
tell you they just lied yeah it's kind
of Genius
I I try not to lie about serious shit
people real interactions big shit I love
a fun lie though like my Uber driver's
gonna think I'm a fucking surgeon and
you know I fully disassociate other
personalities when it's like an Uber
driver or someone else because why not
you know what I mean that's yeah that's
that's where it's okay now let's get
serious here you heard the doctor Drew
Episode last week I came forward uh
as a Predator against myself
I came forward against the sexual
assault I have committed towards myself
during my pregnancy
um it's it's a it's a corny thing and I
didn't really know much about sex toys
until Chelsea Lynn AKA trailer trash
Tammy came on the podcast introduce them
to me now I don't leave my house
because there's really no point
funlove.com is the leading online
retailer of central health and wellness
products offering a wide array of
Premier brands of toys lingerie and
accessories look at this look at all the
stuff I got from fun love this is
date night date night sex toy what a
great genius title okay look what else I
got I don't know how this is gonna look
now that I'm pregnant but I'm gonna have
to try it out I got some lingerie look
at this lingerie dude look at that
lingerie dude that is hot with the um
Darter belts come on get out of here
look at this
don't make me
don't make me chase you
even when doves cry this is a little
whip I'm gonna use this on my baby when
it gets out of line
okay this is my favorite thing about fun
love they sent me a package of a couple
of my favorite things they sent me
a stroker
which is like a flashlight with my face
on it with my mouth open
[Laughter]
so we can you can act like it's my mouth
and you're putting your dick in it to
shut it up because you've had it with
hearing bop bop bop I get it here's a
ball gag which is everyone's dream of
what I would wear during the entire
podcast these aren't even sex toys these
are just for all the time toys
funlove.com is where you can explore an
amazing selection to find your sweet
spot rev up your romance and keep the
passion alive there is something to
satisfy any desire at funlove.com so
what are you waiting for
don't make me Chase you explore discover
indulge and make love fun oh well does
love have to be involved I see what they
mean lust make lust Fun by visiting fun
love.com for a limited time my listeners
can save 25 off your first order that's
a lot of percent off my Kink is saving
money too I mean if it doesn't turn you
on to buy something that turns you on at
a lower price we're never gonna get
along
enter code Whitney at checkout go to fun
love
f-u-n-l-o-v-e.com and use code Whitney
at checkout to save 25 off today that's
fun love fun
love.com two things I don't normally
have fun and love in one place but
together it works fun love.com promo
code Whitney save and make fun love
today
okay what do you want to talk about
because I feel like I've ambushed you
with this
no I I expected nothing else it it's
Whitney Cummings I would tell you
anything and I came on to talk about
Parisian dildos in my asshole and that's
just out on that yeah the friend guys
French guys don't play around they're
wild they really I I learned a lot yeah
and it it was all of August off yeah it
was
damn really wild yeah dude they take the
whole month off it's it was just crazy I
really needed that it like it was a
reset for me I don't know how you seem
happy like you know when you put your
iPhone in like rice and it like comes
back a little better than ever like that
man put me in rice I'm into this like
I'm serious I am really happy you seem
really happy I feel like I feel like
last time I saw you you just had a lot
on your plate yeah shoulders yeah for
sure for sure things are pretty good
right now you need a good rum Springer
this is also for sure this is also just
a great day I'm happy to be here that
was so like corny but I mean it yeah I
also look like you're made of caramel
I what are we doing there's a wig okay
um I'm in my wig area okay guys this
this wig's name is Candace okay I'm
Candace okay yeah
um the real truth is that I bleach my
hair so hard because I never had a
father obviously yep and
I'm bald yeah naturally you know and
we're gluing in we're taping in we're
sewing and we're putting all the
extensions and she's got to take a break
sometimes but here's the thing I
literally I look like Mr Clean I'm bald
so we're you know and I it's fun you
know I've been Tana first I went so bald
when I was bleaching my hair over the
pandemic yeah
um blue and blue every color by the way
and then I just had these like little
French fry hairs oh yeah and then I had
the Keratin bonds yeah and then and then
I just chemo ahead yeah before these are
all kinds of clip-ins yeah no I'm your
Make-a-Wish child right now it looks
good
um thank you I I'm I'm actually shocked
I don't necessarily love and live and
laugh for a brunette yeah I think it's
just I just I feel like me when I'm
blonde or were you born blonde yeah nah
like a dirty blonde but then you know
really took it there I saw one episode
of Hugh Hefner's fucking e-reality show
and I said
get that shit on my head you know what I
mean I never really looked back but I I
don't know yeah like I even just I feel
like somebody's Auntie are you okay are
you the hard Marilyn Monroe
Marilyn Monroe you Marilyn Mojo I don't
um if I am that's a sad Society I'm into
this here's the thing I don't yeah so
it's just new wig new week each week you
might see me with a different hair color
I'm trying them out for a second I'm
into it yeah your skin looks bleach my
hair on Friday but okay yeah I like
what's happening and then how long does
it take to shellac that shit it was such
an interesting process I told the girl
who did it that if I ever do it again I
will need a perk 30 and I'm not kidding
or like a at least a full Xanax like I'm
talking like soccer mom like your kids
are old enough you're mixing it with the
wine like I need that Xanax cocktail in
any bar yeah for real like it hurts it
it really really hurts like my shit's
like cornrowed under this there's a
cultural appropriation Scandal right
under this you know so if it hurts more
to look like Smithers if if the views
are down I can just rip it off you know
what I mean but like fuck dude I don't
it was it was a painful and interesting
process it sucks because the things that
women put in their hair because they've
gone bald make you more bald sometimes
just like how fake eyelashes rip out
your real eyelash absolutely you're just
like how do I because I'm like a
hairless cat yeah what should I put on
everything ever you know but the tour
tour is going really good
I I don't know what it is I toured a lot
when I was younger and I love it it's so
fucking fun it's so rewarding the
adrenaline is so great the highs are so
great the meet and greets are people
it's fun as fuck
you know and I I say that all before I
say this but like
it is very easy to get burnt the fuck
out if you don't really draining manage
it properly and I I'm just older now I
have I hadn't toured since before the
pandemic so it's like it's been like
some years and sincerely my body just
doesn't have it like we we did
it looks like three shows it wasn't um
we had we were doing multiple shows what
we did Connecticut and Pennsylvania and
it was five shows in a row like no day
so you did like two shows a night two
show or one night two shows and I
another show yeah like just this whole
clusterfuck for five days yeah and it
was great it was like amazing but like
that fourth midday you know where it's
like you've done the two shows you got
no sleep you sprintered to the next city
you did the two shots you got no sleepy
when you're on that fourth day of that
it's just eating from the vending
machine of the lobby you're just like
yeah yeah like and I'm just oh I'm such
a cunt you know like you're just so
fucking tired until you have to get on
that stage and turn it on it's like oh
my God please no one talk to me like I
think the key like for me being on the
road it's like I just have to be really
boring I'm in my room the whole day I
don't talk to anyone I don't text anyone
yeah that's how much I have to like
conserve energy because I know how much
I'm gonna have to Output that's what I
learned I think I did this like first
run thinking I was like in the doors
back in the day you know what I mean
thinking I think I was like Jim Morrison
like just we really raged you know and
my like parting after partying after
drinking crazy raging and in the moment
it's such a good fix because you have no
energy and you get drunk and then you're
like fuck yeah let's do this show you
know sometimes it helps because the next
night if you have two more shows you can
go like last night we went to this bar
we did this and it's a great like opener
to like experience the city and talk
about I fell out of the fucking Sprinter
I was bleeding everywhere I have
something going on from it so it's not
cute don't touch me I think I have MRSA
seriously but um
you know it made for it does make for
all these great stories but this next
run we're about to go on I'm flipping
the script I'm giving green juice Plants
don't this is Indianapolis Cincinnati
Cleveland I love you guys but there's
not a ton to do at all you're going to
be raising it Maggiano's Cincinnati is
fucking Cleveland actually Cleveland is
really fun stop so is that I have to go
in the hotel room stop here's the thing
as well with me is I love a ratchet
fucking run down dive bar like I don't
know the like fun pop and shit you know
so it's like take me to fucking
Harrisburg Pennsylvania and I will turn
this bitch into Coachella like that's
the problem and it's yeah so I'm gonna
try it in a wholesome boring way and see
which
which way works for me more I guess I'm
sort of a dork like I figured out like I
don't know it's maybe like eight years
ago like I look at my day as like I
start my day with a certain amount of
energy dollars like I have a hundred
dollars I have a hundred energy dollars
period and then so it's like I go to the
gym that's five energy dollars I talk on
the phone I have these two meetings I do
this like writing I do a podcast that's
like 25 energy dollars so it's like by
the time it's five o'clock it's like if
I need 40 energy dollars to do a show
like I cannot do anything until that
like yeah you just have to know what
depletes you and what uh energizes you
and being on the road by the time I'm
like on one flight and get to the hotel
I'm like I'm exhausted whenever someone
asks me why I love you I'm just gonna
play them a clip of that you like will
Dr like because you're the funniest
person ever and you'll be so wild and
insane and terrible with me but then you
will just drop a bomb on me like that
that like I will never forget for the
rest of my life but it's also like a
great way to protect your energy because
it sounds like hey let's get a drink
before the show you're like I'm at
capacity on energy dollars yeah it's
amazing even I think you're so crazy
they're not even gonna keep trying or
they're like thank you for putting it
that way like I just don't have the
energy like a man it's like oh my god
let's hook up that 15 I don't have I
don't have any yeah
I have it again but it's like it's just
that we only have a finite amount of
energy and I think when you're on tour
you get so excited you get so
adrenalized and then yeah like you're
like signing posters before the show and
everyone wants to come say hi and then
by the time you get on stage you have
nothing to give and the people that paid
to see you you're like I'm so sorry I
gave all my energy to all the people at
the bar next door who didn't buy tickets
yeah it's like what are you doing in
town it's like you know dude should ever
I really I think that operating the tour
with this mentality which I already knew
is how I'm plan on continuing the rest
of my touring career I can't can't be
Vin Diesel I can't be fucking insane I
can't I've gotta like if I operate
without mindset I think everything will
go great yeah I think it's just a matter
of like like traveling we get paid to
travel we don't get paid to do the show
yeah the show's a blast I would do that
for free I would meet the fans for free
but it's like getting on the plane and
is it duh where's my thing and it's just
like yeah it's a lot of even though
hotels you get to the hotel and the
thing and where's my shit and you're
living out of a bag and I forgot
underwear and the toothbrush it's just
sort of like it's a lot of energy yeah
and just cluster fuck and trying to do
all of your other work you know what I
mean and then you get back to LA and
it's like I'm doing 38 podcasts this
week because I was just gone like you
know what I mean like the balance of it
all has come and you probably fly in the
day of
some of them yeah like a lot of them
yeah and that's what fucks me because
I'm like flying the day before I is a
game changer yeah it's just like oh my
God I don't know that I'm like such a
whore about sleep like I could sleep for
18 hours every single night if I need
that's the key to your success isn't it
like well but I'm weird like all week
I'll like get three hours and then like
Friday night I'll sleep for 18 and then
wait for people that can make up for
sleep but like I also look 40 and I'm
25. you actually I say that too her
voice went a little higher her head I
know I don't know I know what you're
doing because I do it and as someone
that has been accused of looking 40
since I was 18.
I think it's also your energy and the
way you can control yourself in carrying
the drama and like my smile lines
because our parents treated us like we
were 40 yeah we were five yeah smile
lines I didn't see that yeah but I know
we all I've got my shit I'm like this
dimple on the side and I was like I
don't see it whatever yeah but like it
is the energy it's the way you can Port
yourself and the feedback that I get
when I when I I'm like because I look
50. everyone thinks I'm 50. the people
that I trust always go you've
accomplished a lot in a short amount of
time and it does seem weird that you are
the age you are yeah that's really nice
it's like that's based on your
appearance it's more your energy and
what you've accomplished when I remember
that you're 25 I'm always like really
but it is more I've been hearing about
her for so long I started hearing about
her when she was 18 like what that's so
fucking crazy like had I known that at
the time I really grew up on you like I
really did it was you and Chelsea
Handler were two of my biggest
Inspirations wild like
two of my biggest Inspirations it's so
fucking crazy to me that like I just get
to see you and you're just like I send
you a mess and make money yeah the Bible
Bible I swear to God I swear to God I
mean Chelsea inspired me a lot too
because Chelsea just did not give a fuck
that's really that's yeah did not you
guys give a fuck and I gave like I I've
struggled with giving too many fucks I
think for a while and like wanting
people to like me and what what you what
I realize is the more you try to make
someone like you the less they like you
yeah it's just repellent like it's
repellent energy you can't control
someone's opinion of you and the less
you care usually the more they like you
but I kind of always was sort of like no
I don't want to upset this person or
offend this person or you know because
it never conveyed that way with you like
it's very shocking to me interesting or
at least for me I never thought that I
was like Whitney Cummings
from day fucking one so that's that's
really interesting to know and maybe
just because I had to like run a
business outside too and it's like you
know what it's like to like be on stage
or you know be performing and do what
you do give a fuck and then all of a
sudden you have something that works for
you or with you and you're like well I
don't they're not Comics they're not
going to get it yeah are they going to
think I'm rough are they gonna think you
know because I play rough yeah that is
hard I definitely let everyone know ever
who works for me within the first week
like hey I'm fucking crazy I sign all
these pieces
I'm white lizzo sign up all of this
right now
um lizzo now that I'm pregnant I
actually am yeah
she has these pants I feel like
um that makes me really happy like
because I look at you and I'm just I I
that's so funny because I look at you
and I'm like I love her and you're like
I love the people that you love yeah I
love you so much it's it's you're
fucking incredible Whitney you really
are that you just do this like you have
are you afraid of anything what are you
afraid of bugs
I'm terrified YouTubers being afraid of
bugs a couple times I just got I just
got Lily sings afraid of bugs do you
think I'm anything like Lilly Singh
just just a quick question like she just
wherever she is right now she just
clenched knowing I'm even saying her
name I actually just lost a brand deal
because I said her name like for a fact
oh my God Liza koshy too but I would say
Colleen banana but she's got a ukulele
and eight children around her and are
you guys I don't know ukulele on YouTube
usually means you're gonna the FBI is
after you from what I can tell that is
so true that is dude I don't I'm sorry
to talk shit about Miranda Sing I'm not
no we can cut this out I'm super not
about it it's just unfollow which is
today's currency of uh to me it was like
the Ellen thing where everyone's like
Ellen's mean and it was like huh like
duh whatever it's like Ricky Martin's
gay we're like What yeah like what's
going on it was like this girl is
offensive and like the girl that would
be like
I was like what yeah dude this is
batshit crazy
this is batshit
oh my God that's so so it is really hard
to offend me I was like damn that's
fucking cold as I should be like I'm
stupid I'm like what what's the skill
yeah the 100 100 and then make it like
weirdly sexual and the audience is all
kids like it was just she was like 56.
yeah yeah I was also like what I didn't
like I didn't know anything about all
the crazy shit she was doing on stage
and the sexual shit and whatever until
like now it is like you're right like
there's 50 of it that's like duh and
then the other 50s that was her act yeah
and it was like why is your lipstick all
over the place like what's happening
like I was like I guess I just don't get
it yeah it's I don't think yeah I don't
think anyone ever got it you know people
just blow up so hard that it's like
undeniable that there's success there
that you're all like oh everyone's like
oh yeah but I also think you have to
understand the kind like the not the
value of whatever the view is like are
people going like what is this are you
getting 10 million people going what is
this
I love value of the view that sounds
like a Tai Lopez book who's that but you
know the one the guy in the garage with
all the cars and he tells you how to
make money but like he definitely has no
money and everyone buys his like little
plants what's this new thing basically
me in 10 years
okay are you brainstorming your vision
board what's happening but also that'd
be a great story arc is this another
bald man who works out who takes private
jet photos who has 2.5 million followers
for no reason like essentially but he's
like the father of them all and he's
like hustle grind yes yes yes yes
absolutely I can't you'd make so much
fun of him you need to do it one one
little I can't with all these
motivational men named like Gabe and
Todd it's all with garyvee and they're
all saying things that women have known
for 2 000 years yeah so they're like
take deep breaths when you're stressed
we're like we used to give birth in the
woods
but yeah yeah that's breathe it's Lamaze
they're like Just Breathe In and Out
drink water we're like yeah no shit and
they're charging 19.99 a month for it
making so much money and like like
patreon well and just like the plans
it's been around for so long what the
what it's like like it's like just
expect you to know about this
[Laughter]
what I'm realizing from this
conversation is I am gonna leave and do
this so you're gonna have to look the
other way but um like it's like a PDF or
like a book or a seminar or an online
seminar where they are selling like pay
to be like me like get my tips and
tricks like you want all these Lambos
like
yeah you'll teach you how to launder
money also yeah exactly exactly it's
like a Scientology for crypto nerds yeah
essentially and just losers who think
what's your qualification
none it's just like some guy yeah
just one guy white guy rented a jet down
in Van Nuys to shoot for the year Gucci
belt every time every time Ferragamo
slides I could like paint it oh my God
the guys I think I'm sincerely gonna do
this though like imagine I did this but
it was like how to manipulate men what's
our last name Ty t-a-i Lopez
okay
God there's always a dog that's not
theirs
oh he's a French Bulldog like he's
there's like in a cold plunge all day
yes yes you know that Lambos don't go
over speed bumps you fucking dorks do
they not no you can't you're useless you
can't go over a speed bump
or maybe it's fine it's so low to the
ground if you go over a speed I think it
was Brendan Shaw like we were going to
the comment store when I picked me up
maybe it was in the other one the
Ferrari and he was just like going
around this website that's embarrassing
that's embarrassing and then it was like
I was like oh my God pick me up in your
hoop deep Prius
that's so embarrassing
that's so embarrassing I did not know
that yeah this guy
um whatever dude I don't know it's like
it's like Tony Robbins it's just like
all it's just like they're like
hucksters yeah 100 100 okay so in like
Jordan Peterson's his like hero yeah
Jordan Belfort even maybe I think Jordan
buffer went on to do that when he hit
like zero started selling plans y'all
know I'm obsessed with liquid death it's
all over my tables you should see the
inside of my car
the inside of my car is literally just
cans of liquid death everywhere I'm
completely obsessed with them I don't do
coffee anymore
um because I don't want my child to come
out the Tasmanian devil psychopath so
I've been doing the armless Palmer get
it
armless Palm or tea this is the shit am
I I'm allowed to curse in these right
and then the bury it alive the have you
tried this one no this is oh dude the
berry sparkling water
ah I hate everyone
[Music]
we're fine I'm a people person now
so good this is my other Obsession too
the severed lime this is like it's like
uh it kind of tastes like Sprite but
there's no sugar it's like limey water
you know what I mean also very fun to
carry around liquid death but yeah while
pregnant because everybody thinks it's
alcohol or beer or something and just
watching people either not say anything
and just be cool with it like I've had a
lot of people come up to me they're like
I I drank wine every night during my
pregnancy and I'm like ah this is water
you shouldn't have done that
I thought your kid's eyes were a little
close together I'm just going to tell
you that anyway
you'd be surprised how many people are
like it's fine I smoked weed every day
I'm like uh now I have to testify in
this trial I love liquid depth also they
donate a portion of their profits from
every can sold to help kill plastic
pollution I drink this instead of coffee
makes me cooler than you you can find
liquid deaths healthy beverages on
Amazon or a retailer near you and good
for you listeners get 20 off their first
liquid death apparel purchase which by
the way are so cool exclusively at
liquidat.com Whitney exclusions May
apply that's liquidat.com Whitney real
quick my friend Kate Siegel who I went
to high school with she's been on the
podcast before
and um she knows that I uh have liquid
death as a sponsor on the podcast and
how much I love them and she sent me a
video that her nephew made
that features liquid death and we're
gonna play it right now this is how cool
liquid death is the kids love it now
introducing
liquidation
are you hardcore hardcore
are you
oh my God
we're drinking hardcore flowers
[Applause]
you can drink it you can freeze it
solitaire
evaporated
[Music]
because it's just water
hardcore water liquid
[Music]
I feel like if you want advice on how to
be successful ask people that have no
like had to work twice as hard to get
half as far yeah and somehow despite
being thought of as unlikable and all
the things still made it
it's not that hard to get successful as
a guy named Tai Lopez I know that's
facts
absolutely like I'm taking my advice
from like a Paul brother before I never
like you know at least they at least
we're just like all day everyday
strategies strategy I don't have time to
write a fucking pamphlet for you because
I'm so busy trying to keep my head above
water that's just saying so do you think
people say that you look older than you
are is that bother you I had a scandal
um when I was like 19. Daily Mail I'm
talking I'm talking like real like just
like scandalous it went real journalism
sincerely
um everywhere I went it was like it was
really like people really believed this
that I was fully lying about my age like
I had to post my ID at one point I think
like on Twitter and be like leave me
alone like stop following me yeah yeah
and it was just say it it doesn't bother
me do I
I also do recognize you know like I got
a lot of failure I I was like
sounds like Phyllis Diller yeah
absolutely like the voice like I I get
it and and just the Vegas like by the
time I was like fucking 15 I was like 25
okay yeah smoking a cig in an Alleyway
like what do you want you know what I'm
saying like yeah so it's all of it
together I don't really take it as an
insult though I think it's just I think
it's taking me a long time I hate to be
this person who's like her people her
people and like try like I took me along
to be like oh it's like ultimately a
compliment I think yeah you know I think
it's like people just being jealous and
like I I need to get her on something I
need something to make myself feel
better yeah there's so much about how
much success she has so yeah there's so
much they could come for and I guess
that's I don't know you know it really
doesn't like because at the end of the
day someone's gonna like me for me no
matter you know like if they like me
they like me if they don't they don't
like if a guy doesn't if he wants a
little baby girl like go get it you know
but okay you're scared of bugs and what
else I'm so scared of bugs scared of you
know you have bugs in your eyelashes and
eyebrows and I know and if I actually
think about it too much I have to like
literally go like set yourself like
straight down I mean you might not with
all the glue they might have died that's
what I'm saying honestly they'd have a
better life anywhere but here they just
see everything I see that's that that's
really fucking sad I feel bad for the
bugs in my eyelashes the bugs have all
died from the Vapes absolutely for
fucking for a fact oh my I was gonna say
something so fucking disgusting have you
read a guy where like when you give him
no no like no I know like when you give
him a blowjob he wants you to put his
dick in your eyes like he's into that
um oh do you know what I mean well
there's like I definitely I'm trying to
think who it was just like these eyelash
bugs sorry man no monetization yeah like
I've definitely like guys like slap
their dick on your face yeah like the
bugs in my eyelashes have like chlamydia
from a SoundCloud rapper for sure I hate
you
like no question on that one like it's
just like a floppy yeah like yeah thing
yeah it's like those those face rollers
what is that what if you just took our
tits and we're like yeah like what's
with the what is I mean it's just like I
I really have to take a lot of
denigrating stuff in the bedroom to like
restore the power Dynamic oh you're so
this is such a boss like I feel like I I
have to take a lot I think that's why I
do like it I feel like we've had this
coming conversation off camera you and I
like a cool six times like we'll just
circle back to this one if there's like
dead dead yeah are you getting fish
hooked yeah yeah
there's dead air like like every time
you and I get suffocated with pillow too
they're holding guns to your head too
absolutely knife play on a Wednesday
like I feel like it's like when you are
so powerful in life it's hot to have
that be the only place where you're like
oh yeah I'm into it but like you better
do it for real oh my god do it for real
you touched on this earlier no pun but
the the fake choke the fake when they
fake it if they don't if you like you
can just see right through them if they
don't mean it and I need to pull my hair
extensions fake it oh my God that's the
one place you do have to fake at it so
fast
yeah oh every fucking time every I had a
clip-on ponytail a couple months ago and
that shit just came right out he was
swinging it like a motherfucking lasso
bro and then I had to walk imagine
walking thank God this was like my ex
and not just like a stranger but I had
to walk out of his house like fake
ponytail in hand get in the Uber and a
bottle of wine and a fake ponytail and
it was like how are you I was like how
do I fucking look drive me to fucking
Hollywood right now sir like oh
I was crying and I just gave you the
ponytail and like went to my room not
one word one thing about having like a
lot of like fake hair lying around is
when I'm driving home from something
I'll usually put it on my dashboard you
never get a ticket it's a way to never
get a ticket in Los Angeles always has
to take care of the dashboard because
like I've seen like meter mates like
they think it's like an animal or
something oh that's actually really
really smart I have a hair on your purse
no one will steal it I love to just
shock someone take out a clip in be like
what's up like it's great it is great do
you think you'll date a girl again
yeah but I don't know I a part of me
does feel like we might have talked
about this uncanceled but I have a
problem with dating
girl like with I don't know how to
explain this but anytime at least in my
life that I've ever dated a girl who
doesn't have the same level of success
as I do they want to like wear my skin
like talk to my exes wear my clothes Go
Everywhere I Go like they're not doing
it for the right reasons and it's like
they've always only ever had like one
girlfriend and they were just like
experimenting it but like I'm the one
and it's like no I'm not like you just
you know what I mean because you have
something they want to be there like
yeah and it's like you know what I mean
and I just so with girls I feel like I
only have ever had success like falling
for and dating a girl if I feel like
they're my like equal or do you think
there's a girl out there who could be
Alpha to you yeah but I just I'm not
into this
I don't know yeah I can't think of a
girl who's like hot like I'd want her to
be hot but then would be Alpha I would
have to be like Martha to do her yeah
which I'm down for I'm no more at the
store you might have your like Sarah
Paulson moment like her girlfriend's
like 78. you might have to like do that
dude I'm not gonna lie that I've never
realized that my dream threesome is
Martha Stewart and Snoop Dogg into it
right now and I really like I have to
sit with it for a second which by the
way uh her you do have to watch her MTV
Cribs because watching hers is the
reason I agreed to do it at all she's in
her one of her million homes and the
entire time and they just left it all in
the entire time she's just talking to
the cameraman like bossing them around
can you back away from the wall I need
you to back away from the wall yeah you
can't you can't put something on that
couch I'm gonna need you to back away
from the wall that is so fucking iconic
she's like and this is where I keep the
dishes I'm gonna need you to back away
from the wall
it is so funny it's just working on the
car right home yeah it's just like a how
wonderful billion houses and she was
like you can't sit on the couch that's
not just never sitting that is so Made
Me Love Her you should just started
doing that to everyone I wish you did
that to me today like when I walked in
she's like in this moment I need you
away from that glass you're just too
close to the glass yeah that's so I was
like I love this bitch that's she's
every fucking thing that's when you date
older yeah I actually want to I think
maybe not me no it's no I mean they do
if they're fucking creepy I mean because
I like I've heard you say before I've
heard you say before like when you came
to LA or like older guys were like
really creepy with you I respect you
you're saying that it just happens it
did that yeah I mean I've gone through
way worse that's not what's scarred me
that's fine
it was like I was like oh like dating
age appropriate like never occurred to
me you know what I mean I thought that
was just like Hollywood baby yeah I got
no father you know what I mean yeah but
it's like I think as you get older
sometimes like where you are sometimes
like to date a guy who's like 35 or
something sometimes like it's kind of
nice yeah like I the last few guys I've
dated are in their 30s if not few okay
save your comment okay it was you know
but I still I am at this weird point
where men will prove to you time and
time again that at least certain men
that the emotional maturity has nothing
to do with the age like I just
yeah like one of the lot like people
that I just like recently had dated is
36 and in my like final text him I was
like you are a man child I just taught
you to grocery shopping like 36 year
olds they were hoodies yeah uh they're
they drive Razor scooters yeah around
100 they wear bracelets yeah so many
bracelets
there's an anklet that matches the
bracelet this is none of this is even an
exaggeration like you have you hit the
nail on that you're going to Burning Man
a week early yeah like to help set up
you sure
mic drop mic drop that's what I'm so I'd
love someone who is like mentally there
you're crashing on your friend's crap
don't say crashing don't ever say
crashing no you're 36. yeah absolutely I
think at one point he was like the new
Olivia Rodrigo it was like fire and I
was like oh my God nothing's fat you're
fired you're unemployed you've been
unemployed for years why do you know who
she is yeah no it's it's you shouldn't
know meet me at our spot yeah like at
all it's so fucking concerned they don't
ruin our streak on Snap yeah what
it's so that's the thing so like a non I
haven't really encountered a non-la 30
sure sure you know what I mean I just
went on a date with a guy who was like
31 and he ended up literally like
stalking me and being so scary for like
a week It's tricky because if you like a
guy stocking can be hot
so valid
talk your shit no because then it stops
talking
actually happier in my living room and I
did not yeah like you just like showed
up oh my God that's awesome me oh my God
but you have to have at least like 30
million cash to be able to do oh my God
no yeah then it's not it's like 50
Shades of Gray it's like follow an air
tag for you bro get me to find my iPhone
that's not it's not stalking anymore and
when I shit that shit out I will just
keep doing it Human Centipede style you
know but so how do you deal what do you
do about that what like what are you
doing you just say I need to get away
for it like please stop was he like
showing up yeah we went on like one day
and then he just like the first time
like we went on one day
I'll actually just tell you this because
you're gonna find it really funny we
went on one day I didn't know what you
did um what's the date what's a good
date EP and LP rooftop okay yeah
um exhausting I met him on a dating app
I love a dating app I love a hinge okay
oh really let me tell you because I I'll
weed out the ones who are like clearly
fans you know what I mean okay I want
the one who's like what the fuck do you
do for a living they don't know me from
Adam or Eve I don't like my Instagram
like you know what I mean you need to
get online like Farmers Only yeah you
need to get a farmer absolutely like the
milk's couch yeah dude yeah no and so
whenever I go like I try to go like two
musicians ignore me two musicians a
normal musicians are hard no it's just
literally a magician is better probably
better I know like take the rabbit like
think about musicians I know I do they
literally go la la la la la
you know how ridiculous think about how
ridiculous if for a living that you're
just like like what that's not it's I I
appreciate it I love music but I can't I
can't shake this one I it might be a
lifelong issue I'm gonna and you think
like you're God like yeah they all think
they're God they all think they're God
and it sucks and I'm just deciding
you're wearing a scarf why with a tank
top and it's so fucked because it's
August 15th like hang me with the scarf
I can't show those moccasins like I
don't I can't on what world every
musician thinks they're Lenny Kravitz
yeah you're wearing a kilt Cafe
on Tuesday at 3pm Minecraft is barely
Lenny Kravitz yeah dude it's just like
it's too much I need to see a collar
yeah that's I know I know and I don't
know what it is but when I get burnt out
on the Kilts and the moccasins I'll get
on a dating app I'll pick a normal guy I
find this guy
and what he's saying he's just I'm some
guy check the a Hawkeye on a dating
hobby is six five you know 31. look like
he had a shit together his job in his I
can't remember what it was but his job
on his dating profile was normal right
it's a normal job and I go to this date
with him and come to find out do you
know my normal job he was like in the
Blue Man Group
[Music]
[Laughter]
it wasn't even a joke
I'm working real job he's like a
birthday clown so anyway
when you're from Vegas
oh I know so no I know but so I swear to
God it wasn't going were they gone it
was really giving something normal
that's what she does when she were
actually live that's really fair
um we sit down at this thing and I come
to find out his actual job so this man
is like six five no he's six seven
tomorrow right yeah six I had him
already go two tables over and so I
always think they're gonna kill me I
love a good I need to make a series out
of this I always make my friend spy on
my first dates and I never tell the date
um come to find out he's six seven so
his job do you know what he does for a
living he's a roofing consultant that
would be awesome he is a scary movie
have I seen have you ever seen this game
uh no sound guy no and that that'd be so
normal he's a scary movie He plays like
the big scary monsters like they cover
him in Prosthetics because he's six
seven like monsters are so much scarier
when they're small like Chucky I agree
that says something about us it's a
power yeah I don't know I'm like I'm not
scared of you fucking goofball like what
do you mean let's chase you you're gonna
hit your head on the door on the way I
mean I can think easily it's so true
like Chucky scares me far more than like
a son wait so he's a stunt man like but
like the like all the Insidious movies
and like all that shit like that's what
this guy does like he sits in
Prosthetics foreign
offer to play Monster no and I swear to
God like his dating app said like
Financial Consultant like you know what
I mean and so that that's just my luck
that's a very like that's so descriptive
there and I was still of course I was
still trying to catch a Vibe you know me
man get up go
um Uber's an app works all the time no I
I see it through I see through the day
I'm debating on a second date and then
it just gets weird he starts he starts
texting me like 30 times you know what I
mean all this stuff she's trying to he's
like what are you doing I'm like oh I
have a I have a club appearance you know
what I mean he's like can I come I'm
like no I don't want you in that 500
photos I'm taking tonight we just went
on one day like it's it was just weird
whatever and then coming at me like so
that's your job like did it you know
just all this weird shit you said that
in the text and then that's a hard pass
for me well it's a hard pass like
playing rough for no reason more so I
think he said it on a phone call but
eventually gets away and I'm still
texting him back again it's hard not to
yeah there's so much going for this man
he's so awesome and uh we're texting and
he's like where are you and I'm like oh
I'm at the club like like it's my
friend's birthday I just showed up for a
second like eight minutes go by I'm
outside I packed a bag we're having a
sleepover come get in the car and then
this like that was the energy and that's
where I was like okay we can't
he says we're having a sleepover yeah
like he he packed a bag
okay he's unhoused this man's homeless
serious point I don't know why I was so
quick to be like you definitely have a
home no he you know what movies aren't
being made anymore right there's no
horror movies they're on strike where
what he's like we're doing a sleepover I
need to take a shower somewhere
Pythagorean theorem like my mind is
blown right now I'm like no way
definitely homeless yeah for sure you
won't even fit through my front door of
course Slenderman what the fuck it is
I'm trying to find you his Instagram to
show you I need to show you so bad okay
I'm into this I mean I just want to show
you one but I can't fucking find it I
like that hinge is your shit
I think he blocked me on all of my
accounts I'm actually not even that's
unhinged yeah yeah and they still
haven't given me a brand deal I talk
about them so much they want that is
wild well because it's just like I think
I give like you won't find love on this
app you know so that's that's really
that's it's you know no but I mean it's
like all practice that's that's what I
get engaged off of Bria
Bible
yeah do you feel anything sad when you
say this no but you do so I probably
should no no I'm banned for Maya because
I was on it at 17 I think I was giving
uh Chris Hansen dude
I got banned for a while because I kept
taking screen rounds because I get it
though it's it's so hard so then I
learned how to take a photo on my
computer like Photo Booth yeah but it's
it's uh now it's like it used to be kind
of lit like it used to be like it wasn't
all just v-necks when I was on it and
also a minor it was lit
it was lit back when they put miners on
it I'm like now they have these rules
those like old guys no everyone's like
from Sydney I don't know no everyone
yeah just friend of a friend why are
they in Sydney Australia yeah do you
know what I do now though it is like
fuck since I've banned from right I do
it to you right now they would put you
back on I've tried
this is crazy that I'm even saying this
but let's say I'm with like a close
friend like he's on Raya I'll take his
phone and I'll be like show me the guys
you don't want and I'll take photos of
them and then I'll go slide in their DMS
how embarrassing so I have DIY
you know which is well because you can
go to their Instagram yeah so like you
can look on someone else's right yeah
check out their Instagram
your mom says we have pizza at home
right at home like it's fine yeah it's
it's not it's all like graphic designers
from Copenhagen it's the don't you think
I couldn't make a better analogy I'm not
even and then it's like to look at more
9.99 I'm like I've got the cash but like
but like I'm good yeah
that's that's a low Point yeah
yeah you just call them friend passes
you just call them it's just kind of
it's like a lot of corgis now and it's
just like and then the I don't I had to
stop doing the dating apps because
geyser is too confrontational with me
like what are you doing on this app it's
like
what the fuck do you think you know what
we're doing here you know what I mean
why are you single like whoa how many
guys did you match it's just like so
confrontational yeah I agree with that
I'm also not texting you for three
months yeah that's before you asked me
out that's so fair it's like I can't do
this it's like one make sure you're a
murderer not a murderer make sure you're
not a murderer combo yeah FaceTime make
sure you're funny let's get it get the
show on the road yeah like you go to the
beach we get it like it's it's also a
lot of black and white photos like men
are trying to be artists and the
headshots that the actors that are
Baristas no they're they're Founders now
yeah everyone's a Founder everyone is a
founder of what yeah like you're selling
drugs
like you're just waiting you're so quick
with it missing I mean it's just kind of
like I a partner it's partner consultant
like no one means anything none of it
means anything uh like you just made my
coffee on Sunset yeah and then I just
want to be the asshole who's like what
do you consider salt for you know what I
mean and then they're like can you tell
dick jokes I'm like I don't yeah one of
us is I'm not fighting with you we have
a friend in common that neither of us
like on Facebook but it's like tinder's
like done but you said Tinder tinder's
just gross tinder's just actual like
AIDS
um like that's just that's even too far
for me that's saying Bumble I don't I
don't know because you can't do dick
pics and girls girls message first I'm
sorry no no dude no dude we do enough
uh-uh oh wait enough
a guy cannot message you first you have
a message and I almost like the first
message from the guy because I make my
hinge prompt one of my hinge prompts is
like it's like totally fact about
yourself mines I can't ride a bike and I
weed I love the impression you just did
of that robot question Miranda Sings
Vibes
but I make the prompt I can't ride a
bike so all the guys who immediately
slide in and say well what else can you
ride immediately now like it's like my
own filter like I can it's a really good
little trap yeah it's to see if
someone's an original yeah because I get
everything of like Whitney Cummings are
you like it's if you make a joke about
my last name homie it's just like it's
so bad I love a homie Zone can you be so
degrading can you really not yeah it's
like it's like I like your little
message yeah I love Lele is the best oh
my God I love doing your little podcast
oh my I just did that to Trevor Wallace
he was like you called the stiff socks
my podcast a little podcast I was like
yo my bad like I know you're doing
numbers I just it's like you're a man so
I meet everything it is like yeah I want
to come see your little show yeah
it disrespass yeah little little does it
oh
it's all in one Suite all in one sweet
ah Shalom everybody we are taking a
little break to talk about Shopify the
Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide whether
you're a garage entrepreneur or IPO
ready Shopify is the only tool you need
to start run and grow your business
without the struggle Shopify puts you in
control of every sales channel so
whether you're selling satin sheets from
shopify's in-person POS system which by
the way send me that site or offering
organic olive oil on shopify's
all-in-one e-commerce platform also want
to buy that product you're covered
um yeah so I use Shopify for many
different things
um I think all the Etsy stores that I
think everything you've seen in here has
been powered by Shopify my hoarding
problem powered by Shopify thanks
Shopify
um we are selling merch for the podcast
and we use the Shopify website it was so
shockingly easy I was like why aren't I
just like a merch mobile why don't I
just do this like I didn't it's to make
it to sell it it tells you who's buying
it and what they're when they're getting
it and what the problem like it's it's
easy easy as one two three and once
you've reached your audience Shopify has
the internet's best converting checkout
to help you turn them from browsers to
buyers in addition to good for you
search Shopify Powers 10 of all
e-commerce in the United States and
Shopify is truly a global Force powering
all birds rothies and Brook Lannon as
well as millions of other entrepreneurs
of every size across over 170 countries
I didn't even know there were that many
plus shopify's award-winning help is
there to support you that is true they
if you have any questions they are right
there to support your success every step
of the way this is possibility powered
by Shopify sign up for a one dollar per
month trial period at shopify.com
Whitney you want to start your business
use me to help you save money on
starting it what else am I good for go
to shopify.com Whitney all lowercase to
take your business to the next level
today bitch go start a business
it's enough already
it's enough go start your business your
soap your hummus your little figurine
look at this look at all this shit I
bought
no easy it is to make shit and have
someone buy it
and then you put on Shopify you hardly
do anything it takes two seconds so if
you make little Gob fake Gobstoppers
from Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
if you make wolves lose sight wolves I
paid like forty dollars for this
start start taking advantage excuse me
of other people's hoarding problems
start your business let's go you have no
excuse shopify.com Whitney all lower
case tell me really quickly though I'm
sorry I have to revisit this just kind
of like how you had to get back to the
Dublin to dildo some things we just have
to know you got engaged off Raya I got a
gay try this was probably like five
years ago to who um it was someone that
was lived in New York and um uh it was
like awesome he was like great and it
just didn't work out
for a couple reasons
care to share the reason I mean yeah
like I kind of sometimes I'm like why
did I blow that up that was actually
kind of great oh my God you're so me
I'll be there I just didn't work out
people are like why I'm like I just
didn't work out though like why I'm like
me
I think it was also like this is the
boring but true answer which is like my
dad just died and like planning a
wedding just felt sad yeah like I just
could like every time that was like
who's gonna walk me down the aisle where
are we like it was just it was just sad
I think I also got a little bit spooked
about the wedding of it all because I'm
actually kind of weirdly shy about
attention when I'm not performing like
just the idea of like people coming to
see me do like vows and like I just yeah
and it's vulnerable and you're like a
tough bitch unless you need to be or
want to be vulnerable with someone it's
rare I was just performing so much at
the time like I was like touring the
last thing I wanted to do was like go
look at wedding venues and get on a
plane the one weekend I had all like I
just felt like I was like can we push
the wedding a little bit and then I
think it started feeling like I was
getting cold feet and it just started
getting would you ever be with this man
again that's possible she has it are you
are you with your baby daddy into
um look we are she's never given me a
straight answer by the way on or off
camera I have asked her 17 times I don't
want to rushed into anything yeah
um I don't like for me I just I move
real slow yeah I used to move real fast
and I move like glacially slow basically
I can't I can't normally I would like
try to be like I respect that though I
totally get that do you believe in
monogamy I it's so hard it's hilarious
because this whole like polyamory
godspeed yeah godspeed if that's your
thing I just like I I think there's
something really punk rock about being
like let's just do this yeah and if it
doesn't work let's just stop I agree
fully you know what I mean like have you
tried polyamory because to me that seems
like a lot of people who are too afraid
to be alone and they're just like
looking for an upgrade because
everyone's always looking for an upgrade
I got like looped into someone in that
situation in like a weird throw I didn't
know about this sorry I didn't mean to
drag you into it and I honestly because
here's the thing I wanted to try it out
and then I was like listen like it's not
that being with two people is wrong like
I'd rather be monogamous and maybe just
cheat can I say something though sorry
that was a joke I'm kind of into a
monogamous throuple that's kind of what
that was that I kind of fuck with the
idea of like we're dating and like I I'm
still on dating apps and I'm still like
dating other people that you wouldn't
know and then I come home every night
smelling like ck1 and Gerard car Noir
yeah you know Paris Hilton whatever her
fragrance is yeah and you just like
don't know what happened tonight you
went to my house I definitely amazed
yeah exactly absolutely and so I I like
the idea of like we're a monogamous
truffle and we like have threesomes and
we all whatever like love each other I
agree with that it's like better I think
that I just realized in that situation
and Bella I love you dearly you know
like so
I don't know um
but we all just weren't very sane at the
time so with let alone two insane people
dating let alone three and I think but
if it was three sane people who just
really wanted that it could work yeah
yeah yeah and I think there's something
like I don't know I
don't know me either I don't know how
long did it go on for
the thrupple of it all probably like
eight seven months was there jealousy in
it
I think so I think that and again
Bella's engaged right now like and is
slaying to an amazing guy who I love and
everything I just think at the time it
she like she liked that Vibe like I
think that
you know and maybe I don't know I was
just kind of there a lot I was there
along for the ride it was really Bella
and Mod's relationship that I kind of I
mean Bella wanted to date me and him
separately and then she eventually just
decided to like mesh it all and so I
kind of crashed whatever and you could
say he crashed whatever like that was
the vibe I floated it didn't go well
yeah I was dating someone and then I was
like really interested in this girl and
I you know but if I look back I'm
probably gonna say I probably wasn't
fully committed to either of them if I'm
going to be honest yeah and then I was
sort of like I kind of want to date both
of you yeah and I just assumed like what
guy wouldn't want to see yeah two girls
and he was like no thanks and guys I
feel like a lot of guys will always like
they want that they think they want that
but then they start to get actually
jealous they're like oh you love you
like this girl you love this girl like
oh no like and then it doesn't you know
yeah and then they're like that's what
you do with your hands yum that's kind
of crazy it is kind of crazy yeah
absolutely that's the other thing you're
just schooling them yeah yeah and then
yeah and we're like speaking in a
different language and yeah let me get
your eyelash they're like what you have
what yeah is that a spider on your face
like yeah then the man is only good for
opening like a pickle jar and then it's
a matter of time before he kills himself
you know
any red flags big red flags any big good
advice you're getting
whoa you just gave me really good advice
with the energy dollars I'm not even I
won't forget that but it's not so it's
not up to you it's like sorry do you
know what I'm saying it's like it's
already predetermined I have a hundred
energy dollars yeah I had this phone
call I did this thing I had two meetings
I needed to if I'm gonna get more energy
I'm gonna have to take a nap from five
to six before the show which is like a
big life hack yeah and then sort of like
I'd love to go out tonight you guys but
I just don't have any energy dollars
left I know and no one can argue with no
that's the thing is I think I I'm like a
credit card with my energy like I think
I have it and then I wake up in the
morning and I say like oh you have a
bill like because like if anything I'm
the one that's like let's go out after
the show like I'm still on a high and
then like the next time it's hard
because there's nothing more fun than
performing live for people that paid to
that love you yeah it's awesome it's the
best it's the best thing in the fucking
you know but it's just like pacing
yourself that's really really fair it's
hard though any red flags any good red
flags any good relationship advice I
heard some good relationship advice
recently that in any relationship you
can be all the things you can be jealous
you can be angry you can be upset that
you can be all the things but you should
never be confused
wow I kind of liked that yeah that's
profound as fuck it's like you shouldn't
be like does this person want to be with
me or not or does this person what do
they want that's so so that's just
chipping away at self-worth and
self-esteem and that's not okay wow no
that's that's just a fact that's
absolutely a fact I saw something that I
really liked on Tick Tock and it it was
viral I'm so Tick Tock so jensy so if
you've seen this I'm sorry but
um essentially it was this woman talking
about how her and her husband the way
that they operate is like people always
say like marriage is a 50 50. and she
was saying like that's just not the case
like if anything the way my husband and
I talk to each other is like I'll get
home from work and say listen I had a
really long day I'm on 20 right now and
he'll be like okay I'll carry the 80
like oh you know what I mean like I'll
I'll clean up the house I'll if they
have kids I'll deal with the kids or
like I'll be way more patient and
lenient towards your energy and so on
and so forth and then if he comes home
and he says that you know what I mean
like actually just being realistic that
someday someone's 90 and some days
someone's 10 and some days 50 50
something that just really like spoke to
me because I think in a lot of
relationships I haven't always had that
like I would I've been with people who
expect me to be like yeah a certain
version of me an ideal of me at all
times that they fell for and I was like
I really want that yeah and the hardest
part of that is number one knowing
yourself enough to know you're at 20
yeah instead of being November 50. I got
this yeah or there's that and then
there's also being able to ask for help
and being able to go like I'm not this
superhero they're like I'm I need help
today yeah like I can't do as much I
love that and also there's something
this guy Stan Tech can um I think is his
name that wrote this book about like the
idea of like a couple bubble like if
you're going to a party with your person
you do a quick like huddle yeah to like
manage expectations to go and like okay
you and I are together we're like we're
going to this party okay I want to stay
like two hours what are you thinking
yeah two hours in and out perfect
Lindsay's here please don't let don't
let her Corner me don't let Lindsay
Corner me yeah I definitely want to talk
to Jenny I haven't seen her in like ages
I don't really need to do all this and
this like like maybe we dance a little
bit I am starving yeah like so if if you
see me getting cornered can you like
make sure I get some food are you hungry
yeah and then you go in and it's not
like you're just going to a party you
guys separate and then you leave and
you're like what the fuck was that I've
been trying to leave for the past two
hours I'm not sure everything in a
relationship really a couple Bubble Hits
yeah on a person who isn't wearing a
kilt and no chain one likes me yeah yeah
yeah it's like just like a good way to
like go in and just like be like we're a
team going into this yeah instead of
like two separate people you know when
you like walking to a party and all of a
sudden you're just like both single yeah
oh my God every relationship
that was weird then you get in the car
and you're like ah that was weird yeah
what that's every relationship I've ever
been these are your friends I thought we
were going to your party and you're like
yeah like you know what happened why are
you pretending absolutely
why did you try to fuck my hair stylist
yeah I know you wanted to hang out with
your friends and you're like not you're
dead you have to sit on your lap yeah
that's so true that's
you're like a dream you are my favorite
human being not absolutely ever I'm
selling a book on the way out because
I've been wanting to read that did you
actually write it I did write my book
and that's amazing yeah the way that's a
compliment in Hollywood yeah I know I
did remember it's it's two you've read
books I haven't yet okay I'm excited
you're gonna write your own book no no
one can write someone's no one's up
who's funny no no one's up here and
you'll read your own
um that was the hardest part was reading
the audiobook yeah oh my god dude I got
like lockjaw if a friend of mine gave me
an Adderall and I started getting all
cotton I just rescheduled oh my God you
can like hear the joke
it was you in Paris oh my gosh um I
thought you meant me and Paris as in
Hilton and it was like a cocaine Y2K
joke but it was a dick in pair that was
crazy that's where I first met you it
was Paris Holden's house really
mm-hmm
and you know what we like saw each other
or something I never remember
her cooking show premiere oh I believe I
got fucked up yeah it was during the
pandemic we were all I did I did
horrible things with Disney stars all
night you know what I mean and it's
always a Disney I think I brought
Miranda Cosgrove oh she's not at Disney
she's but she actually was a a man in
the podcast I love you Miranda knew
iCarly streaming now that's so silly
she's the best she's the best ever I
know she was just really fun yeah yeah
she was super fun yeah I don't remember
the rest but that's where I thought we
saw each other now that Paris has had
the baby I can do stuff with her and
I'll like remember it and like I don't
end up like in her upstairs bathroom
with like my tit out like crying about
my ex like when I need him um the baby
might need a tit to be out yeah I'm not
gonna lie I'm not hungry it's for sure
but yeah all the Paris back in the day
bro you're gonna have kids yeah so many
you're gonna happen I think oh
interesting I know dude I'm such an
adoption person I thought I was gonna
adopt I feel like having your own kids
like getting a dog from a breeder yeah I
yeah I don't need any of these genetics
I'm so Captain Save A Ho as
you're gonna break all the ancestral
Cycles
probably true I would do like a
surrogate though I I don't I was I was
just talking to this too but like I'm so
hypochondriac like I like how are you
how is this pregnancy for you it's not
that hard
it's really not that hard what do you
feel right now that you didn't feel
before physically
um
a little like I mean you've there's a
point where you start feeling them
kicking you know that's right and your
boobs are kind of sore the first
trimester you're just really tired but I
think it's this is what it took for me
to sleep eight hour you know yeah that's
fair it's really fair
um it's not that hard I know women have
nausea like I'm not like minimizing how
hard it is for a lot of people but like
you can do it but like I don't think
that if I felt a kick inside of me I
would be like oh I would be like get out
but a glass dildos okay and I don't know
why it is
dude I was exactly the same I was like
never having kids not carrying it
getting a surrogate froze my eggs when I
was 33 like not doing this adopting like
I was I was there too not that you're
gonna change your mind no but no there's
something about you or when you say that
it does kind of freak me out because I
believe you I if anyone can say that to
me and I believe you like it's you so I
mean if I come back on Knocked Up you
know and our kids are fucking you won't
like you never no one's ever ready to
have a kid and that's you have a kid
then you get ready yeah that's so fair
if you think you're gonna have a nepo
baby because you're still loaded oh
mind-blowing I'm not mad at nepo babies
the way everybody else is I don't I
don't care tap dance for me bitch
okay we got goop out of this like why is
that that is so true I guess it's fine
yeah like I never was operating under
this you're gonna pull a Lori Loughlin
you have your kid Row in the
motherfucking fake books
but like I've never been under the
impression that Hollywood was like a
fair meritocracy yeah I mean I don't
know it's not Nepal like that like no
start your goop like do your damn thing
it's more so like I'm scared of raising
a little fucking an asshole like I wanna
know dude my kid's gonna be broke as
hell I think he's gonna stay in the
attic and he's not even gonna know about
this part of the house yeah Ramen yeah
forever I'm telling you yeah no I'm cook
crush it up I mean North Smith like you
know wouldn't want to perform jokes in
front of him and an award show but he
did um he wasn't Oprah once and he said
something that I really liked about
Willow or Jaden or one of them and uh
one of them came home from school when
they were like five and they were like
Dad like someone at school told me that
like we're rich and he goes no you're
not rich I'm rich you're poor that's how
Shaq is too with this kid I think the
kids go either way they either like work
harder to try to get out of the shadow
of their parents and they don't like
Paris yeah like you know like they want
to be known for their own thing or
they're just gonna be like Chad Hanks or
whatever yeah you know absolutely he
actually works really hard it seems like
he's learned other languages
but like that's really interesting yeah
I don't know I didn't think of that way
because I like I grew up I like had
nothing coming in at this I still think
of myself as like yeah so do I and
that's it's actually one of my like
weird little fears that like my kid's
gonna be an asshole so I feel like I'm
almost gonna double down on that like
I'm gonna be a really chill parent I'm
gonna go black out do it yeah you gotta
just like adverse and then I'm not
sending my kid to one of these schools
where they're like kids have like Prada
diapers and no one's ever been punched
in the face and it's you need to bring
that back I have always fucking said
that Whitney like I'm so for real like I
my kid comes home and like someone hit
me today and be like listen we can we
can figure this out but I'm happy
absolutely absolutely and do I do it
again it's like what Mike Tyson said
he's like the biggest problem right now
in society is that people can talk shit
without getting punched in the face it's
so true I feel like I can meet someone
within the first 20 minutes I'm like oh
you've never been just Molly you need
someone to just kind of hit you hit you
one good time or just tell you to shut
the fuck up dude like so many people
have just never been told to shut the
fuck up my mom when I was 10 I was such
a bitch to her like she was not a you
know she was not present you know
whatever alcoholism like it's you know
and I called her a hooker to her face
when she I was like 10 11 years old she
was like dating and I my sister and I
like stole money from her purse or
something and she was like give me the
money back you stole her something I
said well we're gonna get some more
because you're just a fucking hooker
and she slapped me so hard
for four years I remember going moving
through the air space and time and as I
was moving through the air yeah going to
many other vortexes many other universes
yeah the first thing I thought was
thank God
she finally stood up to me yeah like
finally yeah because guess what had I
done that shit where I grew up in DC I
wouldn't have my face would have looked
different forever yeah you know what I
mean and I was so grateful yeah and I'm
sure I mean she's dead now I'm sure it's
like people are gonna be like it's child
abuse I hit the wall and as soon as I
hit the ground I actually had respect
for her yeah for the first time I was so
grateful she someone finally disciplined
me yeah I 110 just fully agree I think
that I was like thank you dude you saved
me from getting like my ass kicked in DC
by some bitches that don't give a fuck
yeah absolutely they're like high on
Play-Doh I know you know what I mean
like thank you that's a problem too with
LA is just no one there we need we need
to fly out the DC bitches and just have
them for one party yeah and like people
want to be friends with their kids your
kids are your friend dude yeah you
sometimes you have to pinch your kid in
the grocery store yeah absolutely I'll
be in Whole Foods I'm like someone needs
to pinch that guy enough gentle
parenting you know what I mean like the
kids throwing a fire truck across the
yeah that's what I'm saying it's like oh
he just needs to meditate his auras red
right he needs a Benadryl yeah six
he needs a ZzzQuil absolutely fucking I
couldn't agree more oh my God I can't
wait for that that's gonna in high
school at parties we would uh Vegas okay
um we would have um Jungle Juice like
you know jungle juice all the alcohols
with the fruit punch yes but then
someone would come by and everyone can
send into this that's a crazy thing this
was not a drugging situation someone
would come by and put like 30 fucking
Xanax in the jungle juice and then
everyone drinking and we called it Zeus
yeah
and I'm telling you something if my
five-year-old gets frisky he's gonna try
Zeus yeah dude I mean our parents did
like Whiskey on the gums like Orajel who
yeah Bailey's yeah something why not
salt moonshine they're fine they used to
work in factories like 20 years ago
factories now yeah you ever won a
fashion Nova dress shit says help me no
I don't want eczema yeah unless you want
it promo code Whitney I don't know
13 wedding dresses at the price I'm like
I would like to pay more for this yeah I
don't want this to show up like covered
in like children's tears yeah and they
they will it's too much it really will I
could talk to you forever but I could
talk to you forever you've got a heart
out at eight are you already these are
probably already sold out all your tour
dates I think it's a canceled tour
you'll add shows we will add some shows
San Diego
we will do la for sure maybe I'll come
out San Diego and brand might still have
some tickets I don't really know what's
going on I'm just like a little tough
dude is like it's like no man's land
yeah I just did a big weekend of Brea I
love you guys but it's like kind of like
they're it's sort of it's really hard to
sell I just did a huge fucking weekend
whatever
seven shows added two more the point is
they're just kind of rich and like yeah
I think they get their information from
like Billboards yeah I absolutely that's
the only way I love the rich I think
like are you doing multiple radio like
it's kind of a random Market that's well
I'm at the college town and everybody's
kind of gone yeah well the drunker the
better it's a big room though yeah oh
good yeah yeah and there's a lot of like
conservative women with like pink mace
okay so if you're in if you're in Brea
and you didn't have a dad and no money
and you want to come listen to us talk
suck a dick let's go five people there I
end these awkwardly I love you don't run
out I love you goodbye
[Music]